et on va encore aller plus loin avec
vous gotier abinski bonjour gotier large
page consacré consacré à la situation en
Ukraine c'est vrai qu'on l'oublie
bientôt les les 2 ans de l'invasion
russe et on entend de plus en plus
parler de ce double jeu des des
Occidentaux occidentaux double jeu
dangereux d'un côté qui promettent un
soutien à Kiev et qui en même temps
livre des armes au compte-goutte en
somme ne leur donne pas les moyens de de
l'emporter vous vous savez très bien que
cette constatation ne date pas d'hier et
on a toujours eu cette impression et
même cette certitude
que pour ne pas affoller le cours des
choses il fallait armer l'Ukraine pour
qu'elle ne s'écroule pas pour qu'elle ne
s'effondre pas mais pas suffisamment
pour qu'elle gagne et que s'est-il passé
aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs choses
d'abord il y a ce qu'on appelle la
lcitude de la de l'opinion c'est un mot
qui est très très à la fois intéressant
et scandaleux parce que que voudrait
l'opinion l'opinion voudrait que comme
on le voit peut-être peut-être dans les
représentations cinématographiques unee
guerre et bien au bout de pas trop
longtemps s'il vous plaît on la termine
on a vu dans l'opinion un un sentiment
de d'empathie avec les ukrainiens et
puis tout d'un coup on a dit aux
Ukrainiens dites donc il faudrait bien
négocier maintenant négocier
quoi la partition de l'Ukraine alors à
ce moment-là on dit qu'on oui on fait on
procède au dépessage d'un état qu'est-ce
qu'on négocie le le le retrait des
troupes russes c'est ce que demandent à
minima les Ukrainiens pour pouvoir ir
dire on peut essayer de faire quelque
chose sans qu'on ait le couteau sous la
gorge et pendant ce temps-là les
opinions continuent si comme vous l'avez
dit de se détourner or cette lassitude
elle est quoi elle est le reflet du fait
que nous sommes des gâtés et des gavés
de la démocratie nous sommes en quelque
sorte des privilégiés et lorsque les
événements du monde comme une guerre qui
évidemment produisent ses effets aussi
sur l'économie sur l'inflation quand ça
va pas assez vite on dit mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils font ceuxl ils sont pas
responsables c'est et et voilà que des
des chefs d'états occidentaux sont en
train d'écouter alors évidemment ils
sont obligés d'écouter leur leur leurs
administrés mais sur cette pente là qui
est une pente extrêmement d'une part
méprisante peu empathique et surtout
aveugle parce que pendant ce temps là
vous savez très bien quel est le le fond
théorique d'un Poutine le fond théorique
d'un Poutine c'est de dire non seulement
les valeurs les prétendus valeur
occidentale c'est du bidon ça c'est des
choses qui qui créent la division la
zisanie qui favorise des décadences
dit-il des déchéances primo deux les
Occidentaux
sont orgueillisse d'avoir ses valeurs et
ils ne sont même pas capables de les
défendre ça veut dire que une courbure
une courbette plutôt comme ça de
l'Occident c'est non seulement la
sensation et peut-être même la certitude
pour Poutine d'avoir gagné mais c'est
aussi l'incitation à tout ce qui
peut-être de cet ordre là de l'ordre
autocratique en plus petit évidemment
que Poutine et qui des chefs d'état des
petits chefs d'État des moyens chefs
d'État qui se diront mais finalement on
n pas trop embêté Poutine pourquoi moi
j'irais pas me tailler la part du lion
dans le territoire du voisin donc il y a
vous voyez toute cette conscience je dis
pas qu'elle est absente chez les
politiques c'est là que c'est peut-être
plus grave mais dans les dans les les
les opinions notamment occidentales il y
a beaucoup ça et donc on on entendait
Guliver tout à l'heure dire une chose
très intéressante c'est cette espèce de
comparaison que l'on fait entre
l'Ukraine d'un côté et les Palestiniens
mais c'est la comparaison on inverse qui
est fausse on prend toujours les
enveloppes des choses c'est pas
l'enveloppe qui compte c'est ce que les
uns et les autres entendent ont dans
leur objectif idéologique et là de ce
point de vue-là je dis bien de ce point
de vue-là mais Joe Biden n'avait pas
tort quand il a dit au fond il y a une
convergence entre la Russie idéologique
et le Hamas idéologique c'est-à-dire
l'autocratie en l'occurrence là la
théocratie le fait de refuser un certain
nombre de choses de droits aux femmes
aux homosexuels et cetera pas de liberté
d'opinion voilà voilà le fond des choses
et tout le monde finalement fin
d'oublier que le fond des choses il est
là et non pas dans l'enveloppe
extérieure évidemment il y a aucune
comparaison possible entre la Russie et
le Hamas étant donné qu'il y a l'état le
pays le plus grand au monde et à côté
une organisation terroriste
groupusculaire mais le fond de l'affaire
n'est pas dans cette comparaison là il
est dans le dans le substrat dans ce qui
fait la quintessence de l'action de ces
de ces personnages et de ces
organisations vous évoquez Gautier ces
discussions qu' aimerait bien voir les
Occidentaux avancés àoutir il y a eu cet
article du build ce weekend sur un plan
germano-américain les Allemands et les
les Américains qui sera à la manœuvre
alors le le plan le mot de plan il faut
le prendre avec précaution parce que
c'est Bilt hein que Bilt fait est un
journal à sensation mais qui de temps en
temps mène des enquêtes tout à fait
sérieuses je dirais encore une fois
comme tout à l'heure ce n'est pas
fondamentalement nouveau on sait très
bien qu'il y a eu toujours cette
adéquation entre l'armement qui était
fourni à l'Ukraine estce qu'elle était
censé en faire ou quel avantage elle
pouvait en tirer j'ajoute d'ailleurs que
cette fameuse contreoffensive que l'on
reproche en quelque sorte aux Ukrainiens
d'avoir soit mal engagé soit peut-être
perdu précisément si l'armement avait
été d'une nature différente elle aurait
peut-être tourné autrement mais pour en
terminer là le la question d'un plan
Germano américain pour dire au fond aux
Ukrainiens vous voyez vous n'y arrivez
pas militairement et en quelque sorte on
en est responsable et bien allez
négocier encore une fois la question de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'on peut négocier
dans l'état actuel des forces et des des
des des frontières ou des des lignes de
front qui les sépare pas grand-chose
donc à ce moment-là ça veut dire qu'on
va à des négociations qui n'aboutiront
pas ou alors aboutiront parce que
justement l'Occident sera lassé de son
de son amour et de son empathie pour
l'Ukraine qui aboutiront à une victoire
russe et on dira oh on a sauvé
l'essentiel sou on sait très bien que
quand on dit on sauve l'essentiel très
souvent c'est par la suite la guerre et
le déshonneur comme disait l'autre qui
arrive en même temps